[Music]
I'm really beginning to like this place
and the people
starting to believe from the bottom of
my heart that this is where I'm supposed
to be
so
whatever it is that you and your friends
do
please
do it somewhere else you warning me I'm
preparing
is that a Timex
no
immediate nerve
that I'm compressing on a scale from one
to ten
that's a three I go to four you [__] on
yourself you don't want that I don't
want that they don't want that
Padres
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
seconds
beside your fate
[Music]
remember to tell me what did you do back
home
government work I'm retired for you
because of these people I'm beginning to
understand real people
and I'm starting to believe
this is where I'm supposed to be
what happens for you happens to many
times the mafia they like cancer
people's business whatever it is you and
your friends do do it somewhere else you
warning me I'm preparing is that a Time
ax no it's a boost that's the median
nerve but I'm compressed
that's a level three you don't want it
to go to a level four
foreign
like a man who understands violence
you can't take that from me
that can take anything I want
police found multiple dead bodies on
that farm in Sicily did you kill him
[Music]
you might look like a killer
thank you